well i'm here with chris rogers who um i have been a huge fan of Halt and Catch Fire. I've talked about it a little bit in different things. When we talk about TV and when psychology is working on television and when psychology is not working on television, which is most of the time, I think Halt and Catch Fire is a great example of just somebody who really gets character, a group of people that really gets character. I know that you had another showrunner, and there's also a writer's room, and you all had some great actors. But I'm really excited to talk to you
我今天和克里斯·罗杰斯在一起，我是《奔腾年代》的超级粉丝。我在不同的场合提到过它。当我们谈论电视节目，谈论心理学在电视中何时有效，以及何时无效（大多数时候是无效的）时，我认为《奔腾年代》是一个绝佳的例子，它展现了一个真正懂得角色塑造的人，以及一个真正懂得角色塑造的团队。我知道你们还有另一位剧集主管，还有一个编剧室，你们还有一些很棒的演员。但我真的很兴奋能和你聊聊
about the stuff that you've done. You also recently had Paper Girls on Amazon, and then are working on some other things. Anything that you want to say about your history or process? Yeah, the history history of process. Uh, yeah. The history of my process.
你所做过的事情。你最近还在亚马逊上推出了《纸女孩》，并且正在进行其他一些项目。关于你的经历或创作过程，有什么想说的吗？是的，关于创作过程的经历。呃，是的。关于我创作过程的经历。
Uh, well, you just, your history as a writer, you know, future. I don't want to commit you to say anything about something you don't want to know.
呃，好吧，就是你作为编剧的经历，你知道，未来。我不想让你承诺说任何你不想说的事情。
No, nothing is a secret. Uh, right now I'm on the second season of an Apple show called sugar, starring, starring Colin Farrell, uh, that hopefully we'll film next year sometime.
不，没什么秘密。呃，我现在正在制作一部苹果公司的剧集，叫《糖》，由科林·法瑞尔主演，呃，希望我们明年某个时候能拍摄。
Uh, I'm doing a movie project for apple that uh is an adaptation of a ted chang short story i've always loved uh and trying to get a adaptation of kurt vonnegut's cat's cradle oh that'd be great yeah so so you know always a lot of irons in the fire but uh it's a pleasure just to get to you know do one of them at a time yeah i know you had said you were just working on the second season but i looked at sugar um when you had sent that and that looks like a fun premise i'm sure that that's a that's a neat thing to play around with if you've got a big enough uh stock footage light or a film library of archival footage to yeah it's a it's a wild one i'm a little out of my usual comfort zone but i think that's what was exciting about it was to to come's a it's a wild one i'm a little out of my usual comfort zone but i think that's what was exciting about it was to to come into somebody else's um kind of playground and
呃，我正在为苹果公司做一个电影项目，呃，这是我一直很喜欢的特德·姜短篇小说的改编作品，呃，还试图获得库尔特·冯内古特的《猫的摇篮》的改编权。哦，那太棒了。是的，所以你知道，总是有很多事情在进行中，但呃，能一次只做一件事真是一种荣幸。是的，我知道你说过你刚在做第二季，但我看了《糖》，呃，当你发给我的时候，那看起来是一个很有趣的前提。我相信如果你有足够大的库存素材库或档案影像库，那会是一件很酷的事情。是的，这很疯狂。我有点超出了我通常的舒适区，但我觉得这正是令人兴奋的地方，就是进入别人的游乐场，
get to use the pieces they had assembled uh it's the first show i've ever been on that i was not the showrunner of i'm just an executive producer and so it's also a different experience to kind of you know be one of the cooks in the kitchen and that's been rewarding and nice this year is that freeing to not have the i mean sometimes when you like are every part of conception of the character and all of it it's almost like they're your kids you really want to be careful about what somebody is allowed to do with them is it easier to kind of come in where it's more more fun there's less of not an emotional connection but more it's more of a creative thing and less of a i don't know can you could you speak to that at all yeah i mean it was new it's been a learning process for me uh and to
并使用他们已经组装好的零件。这是我参与过的第一部我不是剧集主管的剧，我只是执行制片人，所以这也是一种不同的体验，你知道，成为厨房里的厨师之一，这今年很有回报，也很不错。不担任剧集主管会让你感到自由吗？我的意思是，有时当你参与角色的每一个构思和所有细节时，他们就像你的孩子一样，你真的会很小心别人被允许对他们做什么。进入一个更有趣、情感联系较少，更多是创作性而非其他东西的环境会更容易吗？我不知道，你能谈谈这个吗？是的，我的意思是，这是新的，对我来说是一个学习的过程，呃，而且
be honest it had a lot to do with my kids i um these these shows which i'm so proud of and love to kind of give myself to fully do often function to kind of take me away from home uh and as i was saying before we started i have younger kids um you, after I was back and forth to Atlanta for six years for Houghton Pits Fire and then Chicago for the better part of three years for Paper Girls, the opportunity came up to do Sugar here in town, which would mean I'd get to drop my kids off at school and kind of be home at dinner every night. And so I said, well, you know, for this year, I think that would be really nice. While also giving me, you know, a creative outlet. So it's fun. It's fun to be kind of like on the team, but not have to stay after for, you know, the notes calls. Which is a real, you know, the privilege of being a showrunner, but also the burden of being a showrunner.
老实说，这和我的孩子有很大关系。我，呃，这些我引以为豪并乐于全身心投入的剧集，往往会把我从家里带走。正如我在开始之前所说的，我有年幼的孩子。在为《奔腾年代》往返亚特兰大六年，又为《纸女孩》在芝加哥待了三年之后，在城里制作《糖》的机会出现了，这意味着我可以送孩子们上学，每天晚上都能回家吃晚饭。所以我说，好吧，你知道，今年我觉得这会很不错。同时也给了我一个创作出口。所以很有趣。成为团队的一员，但不必为了那些笔记电话而留下来，这很有趣。这确实是作为剧集主管的特权，但也是作为剧集主管的负担。
Is there more conflict as a showrunner than as an executive producer? Just a different kind of conflict? I think so. I mean, I think you just go to bed every night with the onus of making it work. You know what I mean? You dream about it. When you're on a run, you're thinking about, like, is it clicking? Am I getting the most out of my writers?
作为剧集主管比作为执行制片人有更多的冲突吗？只是不同类型的冲突？我想是的。我的意思是，我觉得你每天晚上睡觉时都背负着让它成功的重担。你知道我的意思吗？你会梦到它。当你正在制作时，你会想，它成功了吗？我从我的编剧那里得到最大的收获了吗？
Is it making sense what I watch? You know, like, it's a running theme. And while I'm very invested as an executive producer um i at least have kind of a showrunner to look to for the like this you know uh which is different well and i thought uh the first season of paper girls was great too i mean i um i i've always hoped like if they're if they're gonna adapt any more of his comics, I'd really like to see the... Oh, shoot, now I'm blanking on the name. What's...
我看的这些有意义吗？你知道，这是一个贯穿的主题。虽然我作为执行制片人投入了很多，呃，但我至少有一个剧集主管可以依靠，这很不一样。嗯，我也觉得《纸女孩》的第一季很棒。我的意思是，我一直希望，如果他们要改编他更多的漫画，我真的很想看到……哦，该死，现在我想不起名字了。是什么……
Well, they did Why the Last Man. They've done Saga. Saga, yeah. I think if you're going to do something in the age of digital that really would be enhanced by that, not detracted, Saga's the one that I've always held out hope would be some sprawling. That or Southern Bastards, which is not the same same writer but it's the same publisher alabama um one can hope one can hope yeah he's he's amazing brian kivan is a sweetheart and cliff tang uh illustrated
好吧，他们做了《Y染色体》。他们做了《Saga》。《Saga》，是的。我认为如果你要在数字时代做一些真正能被增强而不是被削弱的东西，《Saga》是我一直希望看到的宏大作品。或者《南方混蛋》，虽然不是同一个作者，但它是同一个出版商，阿拉巴马州……人们可以抱有希望，可以抱有希望。是的，他很棒，布莱恩·K·沃恩是个甜心，克里夫·蒋画了
paper girls they did that together um yeah i loved that i loved those kids you know I think it was a tough ship to sail during the pandemic you know it shut down a lot it was like kids couldn't get vaccinated um yeah younger actress would be harder yeah I think it was a little doomed by its its place in time but it was there's a lot of stuff from that series I'm really proud of so um thank you for watching well I mean really one of the things that speaks to me more than any of, I mean, really it's one, it is one of my favorite pieces of media, like halt and catch fire. I think I've seen, um, cause it became something where I was like picking it apart and seeing more every time I saw it.
《纸女孩》，他们一起做的。是的，我喜欢那个，我喜欢那些孩子。你知道，我认为在疫情期间这是一艘很难航行的船，你知道，它关闭了很多，就像孩子们无法接种疫苗一样。是的，年轻的女演员会更难。是的，我认为它在时间上的位置注定了它的命运，但那个系列中有很多我真正引以为豪的东西。所以，谢谢你的观看。好吧，我的意思是，真正让我感触最深的事情之一，我的意思是，它确实是我最喜欢的媒体作品之一，就像《奔腾年代》。我想我看过，呃，因为它变成了一种我每次看都会拆解并看到更多东西的作品。
And then it just kind of became comfort TV. Like when I, we had a huge crisis with the business, the stuff, nobody sees like our whole website that books, all of the appointments and everything went down. It had to be rewritten from scratch we're switching companies and it was just like i'm gonna be up for close to 72 hours i'm gonna be drinking a lot of coffee and like i've got a um i mean and i just i like i think i went through the season like four times rewriting rewriting the website it just just on in the background keeping me sane um and i uh i don't know i mean it really it really is one of my
然后它就变成了一种慰藉电视。就像当我们在业务上遇到巨大危机时，没人看到，就像我们预订所有预约的整个网站都瘫痪了。它必须从零开始重写，我们正在更换公司，我大概有72小时没睡，喝了很多咖啡，我有一个……我的意思是，我大概把那一季看了四遍，在重写网站的时候，它只是在后台播放，让我保持理智。而且我……我不知道，我的意思是，它确实是我
favorite things like you see people still find it i mean like reddit and things will just blow up um but it was you know my i don't know i'd like to hear the history of the the pilot but it my guess was that it was coming out of because i i loved mad men i The Sopranos and it looks like studios at that point were like, okay, we need another period-centric or very place, sense of place centric, anti-hero group of
最喜欢的东西之一。你看人们仍然会发现它，我的意思是，像Reddit之类的地方会突然火起来。但你知道，我不知道，我想听听试播集的历史，但我的猜测是，它是因为我喜欢《广告狂人》、《黑道家族》，而当时的制片厂似乎是说，好吧，我们需要另一个以时代为中心，或者非常有地方感，反英雄群体的
ambitious egos in the post-Mad Men world and that was some attempt to do that. And it really easily could have just become very derivative of people trying to recreate that and it really easily could have just become very derivative of people trying to recreate that for the amc trying to become hbo at that point and it didn't you know it became this thing that was like so disinterested and um talking like anything else that was on tv um which i really respected because a lot of tv you know was
在《广告狂人》后的世界里，充满野心的自我，而这是一种尝试。它很容易就会变得非常衍生，人们试图重现那个，它很容易就会变得非常衍生，人们试图为当时的AMC重现那个，试图成为HBO，但它没有。你知道，它变成了那种非常超然的东西，呃，谈论着电视上其他任何东西，我真的很尊重这一点，因为很多电视，你知道，在那个时候并不好，就像你看到了所有那些可以做出的简单决定，然后拒绝这样做。即使当评论家们大多不理解它时，我的意思是，他们在最后改变了看法，但那些第二季和第三季，我有时会对报纸大喊大叫，谢谢，当人们说，好吧，这个节目里的每个人都发明了硅谷历史上的每一件事，而事实并非如此，它是关于我们的伤口如何塑造我们的创造力。是的，没有办法绕过这一点，那不是重点。不，哦天哪，这在很多层面上都很敏锐。我的意思是，我是从外向内还是从内向外？我确实认为《奔腾年代》是电视时代的一个产物，对吧？
not great at that point like you just saw all of these easy decisions that could have been made and then a refusal to do that um even when when critics largely weren't getting it i mean they came around by the end of it but those second and third seasons i was like yelling at the paper sometimes like thank you when people because they're like well everyone on this you know everyone on the show invented every single thing in the history of silicon valley and it was like no it's about how our wounds inform what make us creative yeah there was no way around that that's not the point like no uh oh god that's astute on so many levels. I mean, do I go outside in or inside out? I do think Halt and Catch Fire is a product of a time in television, right?
我经常认为它是历史的中间孩子。《黑道家族》和《广告狂人》，以及被认为是“困难男人”的剧集，你知道，那些让剧集主管和精品电视概念成名的伟大剧集，当时正处于它们的最终季。而我们还没有达到数百万部剧集激增的地步。当《奔腾年代》结束时，人们唯一还在直播观看的节目是《权力的游戏》或《行尸走肉》，因为他们会把人写死。
I often think it's like a middle child of history. The Sopranos and Mad Men and what were kind of thought of as the difficult men shows, you know, the great kind of shows that made the idea of show running and prestige TV were kind of like in their final seasons. And we had not gotten to like a proliferation of a million shows. By the time the fire ends, the only show people watch live anymore is game of Thrones or walking dead because they kill people off.
但当它开始时，就像它仍然是周日晚上。所以我认为我们绝对是从之前的剧集中汲取了动作和线索，然后在中间的某个地方，出于极其个人的原因，决定开始演奏我们自己的音乐。所以，我确实认为这是那个时间点。我确实认为反英雄仍然活着且强大，你可以在乔·麦克米伦身上看到这一点。而且我们也非常幸运，因为我认为我们写了那个试播集。AMC拥有它。
But when it starts, like it's still Sunday nights. And so I think we're like definitely taking our moves and our cues from the shows that came before and then somewhere in the middle for incredibly personal reasons kind of decide to start playing our own music um so i do think it is that place in time i do think the anti-hero is still alive and strong and you can see that in joe mcmillan and we're also incredibly lucky in that. I think we had written that pilot. AMC had it.
然后史蒂夫·乔布斯去世了。我认为很多人都在追逐像史蒂夫·乔布斯那样的想法。他们加强了怀旧和回顾。我想他们说，哦，我们已经在内部有了某种有那种感觉的东西。所以，你知道，能让它被阅读在一百万个层面上都是如此幸运。呃，我们本来会很高兴成为《广告狂人》的初级编剧，但相反，他们阅读了它，说，你知道这会走向何方吗？我们撒了谎，说，是的。
And then Steve Jobs passed away. And I think a lot of people were chasing the idea of like something Steve Jobs like. And they amped up the nostalgia and retrospective. And I think they said, oh, we've got something in house already that kind of has that feel. And so, you know, it's so lucky on a million levels to have the thing even read, uh, we would have been thrilled to be baby writers on Mad Men off writing that, but, um, instead they kind of, you know, read it, said, do you know where this would go? And we lied through our teeth and said, yes.
而且，你知道，开始了这场伟大的冒险。但是，呃，我确实认为《奔腾年代》的伟大特技是，它只是关于人们试图通过重塑自我来成功，让他们的项目使他们完整，以及创造性的伙伴关系，以及这些关系是多么令人担忧。我和另一个人，克里斯·坎特威尔，一起写了它。呃，
And, uh, you know, got to take this great adventure. But, uh, I do think the great stunt of Haunt and Catch Fire is, uh, it's just about people kind of trying to make it by like reinventing themselves and having their projects, make them whole and creative partnerships and how fraught those are. And I wrote it with this other guy, Chris Cantwell. Um,
它是巨人，你知道，它是把我们从迪士尼的办公室无人机变成专业编剧的东西。所以我认为我们的不安全感和恐惧，以及我们那种敞开的，这会是吗？人们会喜欢它吗？它会成功吗？这真的是那些选择中很多东西的潜台词。
and it's the giant, you know, it's the thing that took us from being kind of office drones at Disney to, to being professional writers. And so I think our, our insecurities and our fears and our kind of wide open, will this be it? Will people like it? Will it make it? Is really kind of the subtext of so much of those choices.
好吧，也许这就是它如此有效的原因。我的意思是，你觉得你没看到很多联合剧集主管？我的意思是，有几个人，但通常是一个很难相处的人，与电视网有紧张的关系，但也有财务关系，你知道，你没看到两个家伙相处得很好。我不知道为什么，你认为为什么这对你们有效，但却不常见？这是我生命中伟大的礼物之一。我的意思是，呃，基本上我来自杂志界，我很久以前在大西洋月刊开始工作，当时我搬到洛杉矶为康泰纳仕工作。我想我本来想成为一名《纽约客》的作家。
Well, and maybe that's what helps it work so much. I mean, do you feel like you don't see a ton of co-show writers? I mean, there's a couple people, but usually it's kind of one guy who's hard to deal with that has a fraught relationship with the network but also a financial relationship and you know what you don't see like two guys getting along um i don't know why why do you think that worked for you guys but isn't terribly common one of the great gifts of my life i mean um basically i come out of magazines i started the atlantic monthly way back when i moved to los angeles to work for Condé Nast. I think I wanted to be a New Yorker writer.
那本来是我的梦想。但那种底气消失了。我被迪士尼聘用，帮助将他们的品牌在线转移到Facebook等平台上。我不知道为什么他们认为我擅长这个。但他们雇了我。雇佣我的那个人是克里斯·坎特威尔。我们一起工作了大约一年。我想我们喜欢在专业能力上一起工作。
It would have been my dream. But the bottom kind of fell out of that. And I was hired by Disney to help move their brands online onto Facebook and stuff. I don't know why they thought I'd be good at that. But they hired me. And the guy who hired me was Chris Cantwell. We worked together for about a year. I think liked working with each other in a professional capacity.
然后有一天晚上出去喝酒，承认我们都梦想成为编剧，并且已经放弃了那个梦想。他当时在写一些电影，你知道，他不确定是否有人会看。我说，你知道，我认为最好的电影现在是电视节目。我们开始谈论试播集。我读了他的东西。他真的很棒。我想他一定觉得我还行。我们只是分享了一种感性。我认为这极其罕见。
And then one night went out for drinks and kind of admitted we both dreamed of being screenwriters and kind of given up on that dream. And he was kind of writing some movies that, you know, he wasn't sure anyone was ever going to see. And I was like, you know, I think the best movies are TV shows right now. We started talking about pilots. I read him. He was really good. I think he must have thought I was okay. We just shared a sensibility. I think that's incredibly rare.
我不知道。当事情变得可怕和不确定时，有一个人可以求助，说，我们走在正确的道路上，对吧，我们正在做这件事，我们没有放弃，就像我们……我不知道，试图通过创造性的努力是一件孤独的事情，所以我真的很感激，至少在那段时间里，我们能够……好吧，我认为很多试图讲述十年或历史时期故事的节目，他们只是用它来……他们利用历史感只是为了得到……十年。或者一个历史时期。他们只是用它来……他们利用历史感。
I don't know. It was also nice to have someone to turn to when it was scary and uncertain and go, we're going the right way right like we're doing this we're not giving up like we I don't know it's a lonely thing trying to reach a creative endeavor through so I'm really grateful that for at least that time we were able to kind of well I think a lot of shows too that are trying to tell the story of like a decade or a period of history they just sort of use it to get they use the sense of history just to get to the the story of like a decade. Or a period of history. They just sort of use it to get. They use the sense of history.
只是为了得到他们角色弧线的必然性。但像这样。你的节目确实……你看着人们成长。改变并互动。然后忘记他们是谁。并记住他们是谁。以极其诚实的方式。
Just to get to the inevitabilities of their character arc anyway. But like this. Your show does kind of. You watch people grow up. And change and interact. And then forget who they are. And remember who they are. In ways that are incredibly honest.
就像节目的不安全感在改变，你知道，几乎就像编剧室在成长一样。你和哈莫尼·科林是我在电影写作中唯一让我恐慌发作的人。我的意思是，我在地板上崩溃了，我的……当时是一个新手爸爸，要做所有这些事情，比如你必须成为的父母未活出的生活，你知道，卡尔·荣格说的，未活出的生活，
And like the insecurities of the show change you know almost like as the writing room grows up or something like that i you and harmony corinne are like the only people that have ever given me a panic attack through writing film i mean i had a like meltdown on the floor my um was like a new dad and do all this stuff with like the unlived life of the parent that you have to be, you know, that Carl Jung said, the unlived life,
父母，孩子生活中最大的力量，以及所有那些你没有意识到或付诸行动的创造性东西，你的孩子会感受到你对此的某种愤怒。他们试图把它作为他们的项目来承担。如果你不完成你的项目。所以，从你的屁股上站起来做事情的原因之一就是为了那个。所以，加上所有关于这个的不安全感。然后我认为那一集叫《巨人》，但那是乔在挖洞，唐娜在
the parents, the biggest force in the child's life and all that creative stuff that you haven't realized or acted on your kids feel your sort of anger at that. And they try and take that on as their project. If you don't do your project. So one of the reasons to kind of get off your ass and do stuff is for that. And so like add all this insecurity about that. And then I think it's the episode is called giant but it's where jordan is digging the hole and donna's on
出差，他们要回来了，这其中可能会有一些剧透，如果你还没看过《奔腾年代》，你应该看一看，如果有什么大的剧透，我会尽量标记出来，因为我想谈谈一些更细致的东西。嗯，但是像……呃，他在挖一个洞来向他们证明，他认为他应得的或应该创造的东西并不存在，而洞是空的，你知道，他喝得太多了，女孩们试图帮助他，他的妻子回来想说，哦，我犯了一个错误，然后看到像……而且像所有这些，我的意思是，我真的……我在地毯上有五分钟无法呼吸，就像它……我不知道。
the business trip and they're coming back and there probably will be some spoilers in this you should watch hot and catch fire if you haven't seen it i'll try and flag where those start if there's big ones because i would like to talk about some of the more granular things um well but like uh he's digging a hole to prove to them that's something that he thinks he deserves or should create doesn't exist and the hole's empty and you know he's drank too much and the girls are trying to help him and his wife's coming back to be like oh i made a mistake and then seeing like and like all of that i mean i i really like i had five minutes on the carpet where i couldn't breathe like it it was, I don't know.
那是好的写作。干得好。是的，我想我也要说对不起。但我知道你的意思。我的意思是，这很有趣。我正在做，我想我做这本《猫的摇篮》书的原因是，当我在16或18岁或无论多大时读它时，它确实做到了。它给了我这种存在主义的，就像我读完这本书后五到十分钟都无法动弹，它只是对我做了些什么。我想你知道我们想要……我不知道
That's good writing. Good job. Yeah, I guess I'm also going to say I'm sorry. But I know what you mean. I mean, it's interesting. I'm doing, I think the reason I'm doing this Cat's Cradle book is when I read it at 16 or 18 or whatever I was, it did. It gave me like this existential, like I couldn't move for like five to ten minutes after finishing this book it just did something to me I think that you know we want I don't know
我的意思是，最好能有一种启迪或扩展艺术体验，但嘿，你知道，恐慌发作也可以，但我认为它对我来说绝对是启迪和扩展的，你知道，很多东西我只是不知道它在那里，你知道，就像我不会知道它在那里。是的。但它是，而且你知道，
I mean I preferably be nice to have like an enlightening or an expanding experience of art but hey you know panic attack will take but I think it was definitely enlightening and expanding for me you know a lot of it I just didn't know that was there, you know, like I wouldn't have known that was there. Yeah. But it was, and you know,
但是，孩子们，孩子们长大了，家庭动态在你的节目过程中发生了变化，角色逃避的东西几乎每一季都在以一种现实的方式改变。就像它不只是感觉像，
but the, the kids, the kids grow up, the, the family dynamics change over the course of your show, what the characters are running from changes almost every season in a way that's realistic. Like it doesn't just feel like,
好吧，我们必须进入下一件事，因为我们必须以某种方式从德克萨斯搬到加利福尼亚，因为七十年代变成了八十年代，变成了九十年代。嗯，所有这些东西都非常像，他说它几乎就像黄金时代的继子或中间地带，
well, we got to get to the next thing because somehow we have to move from Texas to California because the seventies became the eighties became the nineties. Um, and, and all of that stuff was so like, he said that it was almost like the stepchild or the in-between of the golden age,
你知道，过渡到尖叫或流媒体之类的，这对我来说很有趣，因为它有点是关于X世代的，你知道，就像孩子们在最后……嗯，你知道，就像海莉在告诉每个人关于他们在佛教寺庙里的美妙经历……而且听起来他们正在经历愤怒之类的，我不知道它是否是……是的，我认为这就是它应该
you know, transitioning to screaming or streaming or something, which is kind of funny to me because it sort of is about Gen Xers, you know, like the, when the kids are at the end um you know like hayley's telling everybody about this wonderful experience uh that they're having in the buddhist temple and um it sounds like they're going through anger wad or something i don't know if it's uh yeah i think that's what it's supposed
的样子。是的，是的，是的，但你可以……是的，我只是……你可以快进六年，就像，哦，这是我在小学时去过他家的每个人的哥哥。而且，你知道。是的，是的。我认为那是对的。我的意思是，那是，最终成为了，令人愉快的是能够生活
to be yeah yeah yeah but you can yeah i just you could fast forward like six years and it was like oh here's the older brother of everybody who I went over to the house in elementary school. And, you know. Yeah, yeah. I think that's right. I mean, that was, ended up being the, what was so delightful about it was getting to live
和所有那些角色在一起那么久，并从内到外拥有他们的生活。我不知道该如何强调这一点，但《奔腾年代》如此独特的地方，至少是制作它的体验，是我只是认为有一种宽广的开放性，我只能把它等同于你第一次爱上某人，你只是觉得，哦，我不会受伤。然后你全身心投入，就像盲目且非常脆弱地。我们认为这是理所当然的……你知道，我30岁的时候
with all those characters so long and kind of have their lives from the inside out. I don't know how to stress this enough, but the thing that was so unique about Halt and Catch Fire, at least the experience of making it, was I just think there was this kind of wide openness that I can only equate to the first time you fall in love with somebody and you're just like, oh, I can't get hurt. And you just go all in, like kind of blindly and very vulnerably. And we took that for such granted uh you know i was 30 the
他们接手了那个，只是以那种方式做了，从那以后的一切，你知道，都在试图回到那种感觉。我不知道，我想这很罕见，很多人拥抱了这一点，这是一个如此良性的过程，我认为这在某种程度上出现在我们能够拥抱的主题中。然后我们也获准这样做，获准说，这个故事是关于，你知道，
week they picked that up and just kind of like did it that way and everything since you know was trying to kind of get back to that that sense of i don't know i guess it's rare and so many people embrace that and it was such a a virtuous process that I think that kind of showed up in like the themes we were able to embrace. And then we were also allowed to do that, allowed to be like, this story is about, you know,
戈登面对他作为父亲的选择的边缘，以及他感到被什么所束缚。我们被允许去这些非常离题的个人地方。而且，嗯，我不知道。我不想让它变成关于行业和像……的必要性
Gordon confronting the edges of his own, uh, choices as a father and what he feels constrained by. And we were kind of allowed to go to these very discursive personal places. And, um, I don't know. I don't want it to make it about the industry and like the imperatives of
制作商业的东西。但是，嗯，我只是……好吧，节目就是关于那个的，你知道，就像制作它的过程必须是的一样。
making commercial things. But, um, I just, well, the show is about that though, you know, as much as the process of making it has to be.
是的，我想那是对的。我想那是对的。因为我认为如果你不把镜头拉得太远，你可以看到这是很多创意人员试图说，我现在快乐吗？就像……这让我完整了吗？就像我可以……我可以让这个与我的个人生活并存吗？我是否正在把我自己的恶魔……烘焙到我们在这里制作的东西中……嗯，而且一直都有不同的……力量使它成为现实，但好莱坞和科技的现实是一样的
Yeah, I guess that's right. I guess that is right. Cause I think you can see if you zoom not too far out that it's a lot of creatives trying to say, am I happy now? Like like did this make me whole like can i can i make this live alongside my personal life and am i baking my own demons uh into the thing we're making here um well and all the time there's there's different uh forces that make it the reality but the reality for hollywood and for tech is the same
最好的东西并不总是赢，有些东西几乎可以是完美的，几乎可以是美丽的，但它仍然没有发生。我的意思是，如果你回头看，说为什么我们使用x86英特尔处理器而不是摩托罗拉，我的意思是，只是一个随机的人做出了这个决定，每个人都跳上了船，这不是最好的一个，你知道，Betamax可能比VHS更好，但我们有了VHS。而且你知道，在好莱坞制作电影很多时候是一样的，你可以有这个美丽的剧本，你可以有十分之九的人签约，某个高管说不，这就是它的方式，然后是的，历史变成了别的东西。所以我不知道这是否完全是……如果作为好莱坞人士的任何挫折或，你知道，情绪，你看到了与科技的隐喻，因为当我看着
and that the best thing does not always win and something can almost be perfect it can almost be beautiful and it still doesn't happen and i mean if you just go back and be like why do we use an x86 intel processor versus a motorola i mean just a random somebody made this decision everyone jumped on board it wasn't the best one you know Betamax was probably better than VHS but we had VHS like and you know a lot of making movies in Hollywood it's the same thing you can have this beautiful script you can have nine out of ten people signed on some some executive says no this is the way it goes and then yeah history becomes something else so I don't know if that was at all uh if any of the frustrations or, you know, emotion you have as a Hollywood person, you see the metaphor with tech because I definitely felt that when you look at
那些事情的历史时，我绝对感觉到了。哦，是的，100%。我的意思是，我确实认为那个方面是，是非常存在的，但你知道，这很有趣，因为我现在离它有一点距离了。我想我最近在奥斯汀电视节上，他们告诉我们这是试播集播出10周年……我非常感激的事情是制作它的体验，然后……像这样的对话，人们说我发现了它，它对我意味着什么……那是像……有意义的东西，某种程度上持续存在……在
the history of why those things are. Oh yeah, 100%. I mean, and I do think that aspect of it is, is so present, but you know, it's interesting because I've got a little distance from it now. I think I was out at the Austin TV festival recently and they told us it was the 10 year anniversary of the pilot coming on um and the things i'm so grateful for are the experience of making it and then um conversations like this right where people are like i found it and it meant something to me um that's like the the meaningful stuff that kind of lasts like in
那一刻，你就像，我想我们至少和《美国谍梦》一样好。我们没有获得任何提名，但是的，那是自我，它会过去。而且，嗯，我不知道。呃，
the moment are you like i think we're at least as good as the Americans have been. We're not getting like nominated for anything, but yeah, that's the ego and that passes. And, um, I don't know. Uh,
是的。我的意思是，在某些方面我很感激它有点不被注意，只是因为我认为它没有被其他很多东西所笼罩，比如，哦，人们喜欢它，当我们这样做时。所以也许我们应该继续这样做。它在内部非常忠于自己。所以……是的，我不知道，我最
yeah. I mean, in some ways I'm grateful that it kind of flew under the radar just because I think it didn't get clouded with a lot of other kind of, Oh, people liked it when we did this. So maybe we should keep doing this it was very true to itself internally so um yeah i don't know i and i'm most
满足于只是像对我来说重要的艺术，当人们只是说我与它有个人经历时，而且……那是……我不知道，这就是你做它的原因，我想。好吧，而且……我的意思是，我认为营销并没有完全向人们传达它是什么。我真的不知道营销和电视在好莱坞有多重要，所以可能并不重要，但其中一件事，因为我已经试图让人们看这个节目10年了，而且你已经让很多人看了它，但其中一件事我总是听到的是，我不喜欢电脑，或者我不喜欢80年代之类的，我总是说这就像《江湖浪子》关于台球一样，是关于电脑的。
fulfilled by just like the art that kind of matters to me when people kind of just say i had a personal experience with it and uh that's i don't know that's why you do it i think well and the um like i think the marketing didn't quite get across to people what it was i don't really know how much marketing and tv matters as much as hollywood so it may not but one of the things because i've been trying to get people to watch the show for 10 years and you've gotten a lot of people to watch it but one of the things i would always hear is like i don't like computers or i don't like 80s whatever and i was always like this is as much about computers as the hustlers about pool.
是的。你在看一张台球桌，但那不是，它是一个隐喻。这是一个该死的奇怪标题。是的。我明白了。在顶部内置了一种进入壁垒。
Yeah. You're looking at a pool table, but that's not, it's a lift. It's a fucking weird title. Yeah. I get it. There's a barrier to entry kind of built in right at the top.
而且我，你知道，我确实认为这个，第一季有很多那种东西。我们试图弄清楚，我们试图复制我们喜欢的节目，我们就像，这是《广告狂人》吗？这是，
And I, you know, and I do think this, the first season has a lot of that. We're trying to figure, we're trying to copy the shows we like where we're like, is this mad man? Is this,
你知道我的意思吗？我想你可以感觉到我们像是在模仿我们认为电视节目应该是什么样子。直到节目的第二季，我才觉得我们只是在孤注一掷，演奏我们自己的音乐。所以我认为进入这个节目有时也会是一段颠簸的旅程。所以第一季结合得相当扎实，节奏也加快了
you know what I mean? I think you can feel us like kind of aping the, what we think TV shows are supposed to be. And it really isn't until the second season of the show that I feel like we're just like going for broke playing our own music. So I think it also kind of can be a bumpy ride to get into the show sometimes. So the first season hangs together pretty solid and the pacing of it ramps up
到最后。就像这很有趣。嗯，技术的关系，以及你用它带走了多少肝脏？我的意思是，有些事情不像后来那样一致，但我不知道这就是为什么有人在看它。我的意思是，
to the end. Like it's funny. Um, the relationship of technology and like how many livers do you take with it? I mean, some things are not as consistent as they get to be later, but I don't know that that's why anyone's watching it. I mean,
试播集确实感觉更像是，你知道，试图找到《广告狂人》、《黑道家族》、《绝命毒师》类型的反英雄。你怎么……你知道，美国精神病人真的是一个社会病态者吗？或者你知道，好莱坞华尔街，你知道，那里有什么是人性化的吗？或者你，或者我，或者所有那些大问题，但它并没有真正深入到那里。我的意思是，乔比……那个角色可能被写成的方式要复杂得多，而且已经被写了很多次。我的意思是，你有一些非常非常好的演员，他们以一种我想当时每个人都负担得起的方式走到了一起。是的，我的意思是，那改变了什么吗？就像你在写它很久
the pilot does feel more like, you know, trying to to find a madman soprano's breaking bad type antihero how do you what is the you know is the american psycho really a sociopath or you know the hollywood wall street you know is there something there that's human or not or you or me or all those big questions but it doesn't really go there as much i mean joe's so much more complicated than um what what that how that character could have been written and like has been written a lot of times i mean you had really really good actors uh that kind of came together in a way that i guess everyone was affordable at that time yeah i mean what was that did that change anything like you're writing it long
在他们做之前，但你反思表演或通过那里看到东西。不，你抢先了。那改变了一切，你知道，那仍然是一个你会去拍摄试播集然后写其余部分的时间，所以我们拍摄了那个试播集，就像某些东西直接跳出了屏幕。你知道，呃，像麦肯齐·戴维斯，当时基本上是一个新人，我觉得她演卡梅伦·豪太好了。就像，好吧，我们必须写进这个，我们选了托比·哈斯演博斯沃思。它本来应该只是那种通用的硬汉，但他有点温暖和有趣。就像，哦，写进那个。呃，然后乔和戈登，你知道……我想有一个版本的乔，他
before they're doing it but you reflect on a performance or see things through there no you beat me to it uh that changes everything you know and it was still a time where you would go film the pilot and then write the rest of it and so we filmed that pilot and just like certain things just jumped off the screen to us you you know, uh, where, you know, like Mackenzie Davis, who is basically a newcomer at that time, I thought was so good as Cameron Howe. It was like, well, we got to write into this and we cast Toby Huss as Bosworth. It was supposed to just be kind of this generic hard ass, but then he was kind of warm and funny. And it was like, Oh, right into that. Uh, and then Joe and Gordon, you know know i think there was a version of joe where he
只是唐·德雷珀，他总是对的，然后我想当我们做了试播集时，我们就像，感觉他有点在装模作样，感觉他有点不确定，感觉如果他被这些质疑那种像他正在做的史蒂夫·乔布斯印象的表象，或者如果他实际上从史蒂夫·乔布斯那里偷了台词的人所困扰，那会很有趣。同样，你知道，戈登只是那种天才，我们可以给他像挖那个洞这样的东西，他可以成功，你不能对每个人都这样做。所以，嗯，在成功中，我认为一部伟大的剧集是一个反馈循环，你只是看到什么在起作用，然后你倾向于更多那样做。你知道，随着那一季的进行，我们在卡梅伦和唐娜之间做了一个场景，我们就像，哦，这是……这是某种东西，你知道，呃，所以我认为这就是在起作用，你倾向于更多那样做。你知道，随着那一季的进行，我们在卡梅伦和唐娜之间做了一个场景，我们就像，哦，这是某种东西，你知道，呃，所以我认为
was just don draper and he was always right and then i think when we kind of did the pilot we're like it feels like he's kind of faking it it feels like he's kind of not sure and it feels like it would be interesting if he was like kind of wrong-footed by these other people that kind of questioned that veneer of like kind of the steve jobs impression he's doing or if he actually stole lines from steve jobs and then likewise you know gordon was just so kind of brilliant and we could give him stuff like digging that hole and he could pull it off and you can't do that for everybody and so um in success a great show i think is a feedback loop and you just see what's working and you kind of go more of that you know not as that season went on we did a scene between cameron and donna and we're like oh this is this is something you know uh so i think that's what's working and you kind of go more of that you know as that season went on we did a scene between cameron and donna and we're like oh this is this is something you know uh so i think
这就是它真正有趣的地方。有一部你着手写的剧，和一部你……最终写的剧。如果你不听剧集的，我只是认为你留下了太多东西。所以那个……是的，你一针见血，这很大程度上是关于我们选了谁，这完全改变了它。我喜欢乔的方式……所以就像如果乔进入荣格分析，你知道……如果他没有进入精神分析，而是被带向了一个完全不同的方向。我的意思是，我认为那种被概念化的方式就像这个人极其直觉，只是深深地无意识地直觉，但这不是一个选择。
that's what's really fun about it there's a show you set out to write and show you um ultimately do right and if you're not listening to the show i just think you leave so much on the table and so that uh yeah you hit the nail on the head it was so much about who we cast and that changed it completely the the thing that i love about the way that joe um so like if joe came into jungian analysis you know um what if he didn't go into psychoanalysis and it was taken a totally different 40 in direction i mean i think like what the way that that would be conceptualized is like this person is incredibly intuitive just deeply unconsciously intuitive, but it's not a choice.
所以他无法，他总是在做一个梦，并试图重新连接到妈妈在生命尽头所做的梦。但是，嗯，那是他最后一次被这种东西所包含和持有，
So he's not able to, he's always dreaming a dream and trying to reconnect to the dream that mom was having, you know, at the end of her life. But also, um, that was the last time he was kind of contained and held by this thing,
但他无法做自己的梦。所以它变成了一种寄生性的东西，就像让我激励你，但随后慢慢地，因为我……这不是一个选择，我要接管它。而且只是在视觉上，我的意思是，每次你看到他没问题，然后你意识到他不是，他正在反映未来五年会发生什么的愿景，因为他无法停止看到未来。我的意思是，只是他看起来像一个快乐家伙的第一个场景，从一个角度看。然后从背后的角度，你看到他正在看一个卡尔文·克莱恩的广告牌，
but he can't dream his own. So it becomes this parasitic thing where it's like let me inspire you but then slowly because i'm this isn't a choice i'm going to take that over and just visually i mean every time you see him being okay then you realize he's not he's reflecting a vision of what's coming in the next five years because he can't stop seeing the future and i mean just the first scene of him looking just like a happy guy from one angle. And then from the back angle, you see that he's looking at a Calvin Klein billboard
然后他解开了这个扣子，脱掉了他的领带，因为他试图比现在多一点点下一个东西，以一直挑战每个人。我的意思是，他看着金门大桥的美妙推拉变焦，所有这些，
and then he unbuttons this button that takes off his tie because he's trying to be a little bit more of the next thing than the right now to challenge everybody all the time. And I mean, the wonderful dolly zoom of him looking at the Golden Gate Bridge, all of those,
所有这些东西，就像你，你看到这个家伙直到最后，从来没有真正成为一个独立的个体。他总是如此无意识地寻求一个家庭，以至于他自己的创造力之外没有创造力。就像它只是他的，它必须连接到别人的梦，
all of those things, like you, you see this guy until the very end, not really ever be an individual. He's always so unconsciously seeking a family that there's no creativity outside of his own. Like it's just his, it has to be connected to somebody else's dream,
你知道，直到最后一个镜头，他有点能看到他的生活，这就像第一次是一个人，但可能，你知道，也比他以往任何时候都更不重要。你知道，我……是的，我喜欢这一切，李·佩斯用它做了很多精彩的事情，但对我来说，第三季也是……是一种……我不知道，他有点触底反弹。他在他与瑞安的旧金山努力之后，你知道，和一些悲剧，然后那种回到Comdex并有点复活的版本，我不知道，那……那真的有点
you know, until the last shot where he kind of can see his life and it's like a person for the first time but probably you know also less important than he's ever been you know i yeah i love it all and lee paste did so much brilliant stuff with it but for me that third season too is is kind of such a i don't know he kind of hits a rock bottom he kind of he kind of goes all the way down after kind of his san francisco endeavor with ryan you know and some tragedy and then the kind of like version of him that comes back to comdex and kind of comes back to life i don't know that that's that that's really kind of
我觉得那是新乔的火花，这让我非常满足。就那些假装直到生活中的大悲剧迫使他们去问我为谁假装的人而言，这感觉非常真实。而且……我只是认为他演得太美了。那个演员。最后一季有很多室内场景，就像更有限的场景。那是……那是某种东西吗，呃，你有点在写约束？他们说你钱少了，但我们想完成它，因为我们认为它会成为Netflix会流媒体播放的东西。他们当时看到这部剧有更长的生命力了吗？而且是，还是……
i feel like the spark of some new joe in that and that was very satisfying to me that felt very real in terms of people that kind of fake it until big tragedies in their life kind of forced them to kind of go who am i faking it for and uh i just thought he did that so beautifully uh that actor the last season there's a lot that's indoor it's like more limited sets was that was there was that a thing where um you're kind of riding to the constraint like do they say you have less money but we want to finish it because we think it's going to go be something that Netflix is going to stream. And were they seeing the show had longer legs at that point? And were, or was that,
你有同样类型的预算吗？而那只是你选择写它的方式。因为它更亲密，你知道，最后一季更多是人们围着桌子说话。它效果很好。我只是总是很好奇。是的。我的意思是，我不得不说，这就是我作为编剧最喜欢做的事情。这很有趣，对吧？
did you have access to the same kind of budgets? And that was just the way you chose to write it. Because it's a lot more intimate, you know, that last season is a lot more people talking around a table. It works well. I just was always curious. Yeah. I mean, I got to say, that's what I love to do the talking around a table. It works well. I just was always curious. Yeah, I mean, I got to say, that's what I love to do the most as a writer. It's interesting, right?
因为我现在正在做这个节目，《糖》，这是一部侦探片。有大的场景之类的。我总是试图把它引向，是的，但如果他在餐馆里表达情感呢？我只是认为这就是我所爱的。到第四季时，我们对他们所有人都太了解了，以至于就像，我想去戈登的生日派对。我想，我想和鲍勃以及他的孩子在一起。
Because I'm on this show, Sugar, right now, which is a detective piece. And there's big set pieces and stuff. And I'm always kind of trying to drive it towards, yeah, but what if he was in a restaurant emoting? I just think that's what I love. And we knew them all so well by the fourth season that it was like, I want to like go to Gordon's birthday party. I want to, I want to like be with Bob and his kid.
我不知道。有，我认为这就是感觉如此吸引人的原因，因为我们对角色太了解了，但摄像机离他们更近。是的。是的。我们知道，但我们也知道它要结束了。
I don't know. There were, I think that's just what felt so attractive because we knew the characters so well, but the camera's closer to them. Yeah. Yeah. We knew, but we also knew it was ending,
我不知道。我想这就是最吸引人的地方，因为我们对角色非常了解，但镜头却离他们更近了。是的。是的。我们了解，但我们也知道它要结束了。
which was a gift that, that, you know, every season you kind of write to a cliffhanger, but try to tell yourself, okay, if they don't renew it, at least we've given enough closure that people aren't gonna be like oh but like you know giving it a place to go and so it was trying to say goodbye a lot of that last season and so that some of the stuff that just kind of still kills me about it is uh you know
这真是一份礼物，你知道，每一季你都会写到一个悬念，但会试着告诉自己，好吧，如果他们不续订，至少我们已经给出了足够的结局，让观众不会觉得……你知道，给它一个归宿。所以最后一季很大程度上是在试着说再见，这也是为什么有些事情直到现在想起依然让我心痛，呃，你知道。
like that phoenix scene in the last episode where cameron and donna talk about like the company they won't have and obviously the episode uh you know after we lose gordon and um just because they were old friends to us by then so so i guess i mean we're choosing it we never had much money at all so that you probably feel that too but um you know you have even less by the fourth season just because everything costs a little more each year so maybe we're doing that too well and maybe i'm not reading it right but one of the things that seem to be implied is you know a lot of cameron's arc is that you know her dad is in the military and dies and she's a punk rocker and she maybe marries a version of her dad at some point or there's something there but it looks like you know if phoenix doesn't happen and she ends up going a different direction it's likely that what she's working on is going to become military
就像最后一集里那个凤凰城的场景，卡梅伦和唐娜谈论着她们不会拥有的公司，显然那一集是在我们失去戈登之后，呃，你知道，因为那时他们对我们来说已经是老朋友了。所以我猜，我的意思是，我们选择了它，我们从来没有多少钱，所以你可能也能感觉到，但是，呃，你知道，到了第四季钱就更少了，因为每年每样东西的成本都在增加，所以也许我们做得太好了，也许我解读得不对，但其中一个似乎暗示的事情是，你知道，卡梅伦的很多成长弧线是，你知道，她父亲在军队服役并去世了，她是个朋克摇滚乐手，她可能在某个时候嫁给了一个像她父亲那样的人，或者类似的事情，但看起来，你知道，如果凤凰城项目没有发生，她走向了另一个方向，很可能她正在从事的工作会变成军事
contractor technology so i don't know i don't know that was intentional but that was definitely when she's i forget the name of the the agent who's like courting her with the bangs who's talking to her in the trailer but yes when i was watching those i was being like i don't know i didn't know how intentional that was but that's what i was like i know what she's talking to you about i know what you're gonna be i know what you're gonna be doing in 15 years if you make it i mean a thing i wanted to say at some point on this podcast is i am such a strong believer in that kind of death of the author thing i'm like sure there's what i intended when it left my fingertips. But then a million people touched it between then and when it went on screen. And what it means to you is just as valid as kind of like the top spin I tried to put on it by then.
承包商技术，所以我不知道，我不知道那是否是有意的，但那绝对是当她……我忘了那个留着刘海、在预告片里和她说话、试图拉拢她的经纪人的名字了，但是的，当我观看那些片段时，我心想，我不知道，我不知道那有多大程度是有意的，但我当时的感觉是，我知道她在和你谈论什么，我知道如果你成功了，15年后你会成为什么样的人，你会做什么。我的意思是，我想在这个播客上说的一件事是，我非常坚信那种“作者已死”的理论，我确定当我写下这些文字时，我有我的意图。但在它最终呈现在屏幕上之前，有数百万人接触过它。它对你意味着什么，和我当时试图赋予它的意义一样有效。
You know, so I don't know. I don't think there's any right or wrong answer. I think that's I had never thought about that. I think that's compelling. And I wish I had thought of that. Well, it's not over. But the show is written in this open way. I mean, the moments that,
所以，我不知道。我不认为有什么正确或错误的答案。我想那是……我从来没想过这一点。我觉得这很有说服力。我真希望我当时想到了这一点。好吧，它还没有结束。但这部剧是以这种开放的方式编写的。我的意思是，那些时刻，
because I've had a couple of patients that have watched it and talked about it, if it was up their alley and it was, it was helpful for them. But I mean, the, the, the two things that like the moments that I see on the way that y'all wrote that, that you wouldn't see on anything else, they would have missed it or it would have just been too like on the nose it's like there's like a moment where gordon and donna are talking and gordon says donna says something that was very important to gordon was never really important to her and you can tell at that moment that that it's over their marriage is over but it doesn't really end for another year or two
因为我有几个病人看过这部剧并谈论过它，如果这符合他们的口味，那对他们是有帮助的。但我的意思是，我看到的你们编写的那种时刻，你在其他任何地方都看不到，如果换作别人可能会错过，或者会显得太刻意。比如有一个时刻，戈登和唐娜在交谈，戈登说……唐娜说了一些对戈登来说非常重要，但对她来说却从未真正重要过的话，在那一刻你可以看出，一切都结束了，他们的婚姻结束了，但实际上又过了一两年才真正终结。
and you but every moment that you see that after it's her trying to ask him something on the phone. Yeah. They solve a problem together as parents. And then she says something personal and he just kind of hangs, like he doesn't care. Like, or because like the way people change or fail to change is that we
而且，在那之后你看到的每一个时刻，都是她试图在电话里问他什么。是的。他们作为父母一起解决了一个问题。然后她说了一些私人的话，而他只是……挂断了，就像他不在乎一样。就像，或者因为人们改变或无法改变的方式是，我们
experience all this anxiety. And then maybe we put it towards a healthy behavior where we do something different, but probably we just put it towards a healthy behavior where we do something different but probably we just put it towards something that takes the anxiety away that is easy and then we forget that there was ever anything there we needed to do and when you know there's the i think probably my favorite scene in it is donna having this like wonderful reconnection with cameron you know she's smoked she's smoked weed she's like a yeah, she's able to say all these powerful things that she needs to say. And then it's in her head. She never says that, but she
经历了所有这些焦虑。然后也许我们把它转向了一种健康的、我们做些不同事情的行为，但很可能我们只是把它转向了一种健康的、我们做些不同事情的行为，但很可能我们只是把它转向了某种能消除焦虑、简单易行的事情，然后我们就忘记了曾经有什么需要我们去做的事情。你知道，我想这可能是我最喜欢的一个场景，唐娜和卡梅伦有了一次美妙的重连，你知道，她抽了……她抽了大麻，她就像……是的，她能够说出所有她需要说的有力的话。然后这只在她的脑海里。她从未说出口，但她
feels better. And, and because that, that is, that is that thing that is so human and so true and so sad. Um, yeah, you just see all day, you know, in therapy that most people don't get about psychology enough to put it in their character. Well, two things. One, I, so I, I hadn't really, I have not watched any episodes of the show since it was on. And I don't know if that was just like psychologically, it was like too much to go back to or what, but, um, they played that scene at the, this little reunion we had.
感觉好多了。而且，因为那……那是那种非常人性化、非常真实且非常悲伤的事情。嗯，是的，你在治疗中整天都能看到，你知道，大多数人对心理学的了解不足以将其融入到他们的角色中。好吧，两件事。第一，我，所以我，我真的没有……自从剧集播出后，我就没再看过任何一集。我不知道这是否仅仅是因为心理上，回看这些内容太沉重了，还是什么原因，但是，呃，他们在我们举行的小型重聚会上播放了那个场景。
Um, and I didn't write that one. A woman named Angelina Burnett wrote that actual scene you know we break the story together and then different writers go away to execute them oh my god and it made me it made me tear up I that's such a they're so good in that both of them but I also think it is what you're saying so psychologically true you know it's like in the world where we're brave and we say the things we really feel um but I also think back on that, and I think Chris Cantwell and I were unafraid to put a lot of our own very personal shit and literal lines from our marriage
嗯，那一段不是我写的。一个叫安吉丽娜·伯内特的女性写了那个实际的场景，你知道我们一起构思故事，然后不同的编剧去执行它们。天哪，它让我……它让我热泪盈眶。我……那真是太棒了，他们两个在那个场景里表现得太好了，但我同时也认为，正如你所说，它在心理上是如此真实，你知道，就像在一个我们勇敢地表达真实感受的世界里。嗯，但我也会回想起那个场景，我想克里斯·坎特韦尔和我当时并不害怕把我们自己非常私人的烂事，甚至是我们婚姻中真实的台词，
and our marriage to each other in the show. So it's funny. I'll think of fights that characters have and say things like, because you don't like it or because it didn't come from you. And it's like, I think that's us in some way trying to have these difficult conversations with each other on the page like you know because you don't like it or because it didn't come from you and it's like i think
以及我们彼此的婚姻生活放进剧里。所以这很有趣。我会想到角色们吵架时说的话，比如“因为你不喜欢它”或者“因为它不是出自你之手”。就像，我认为那在某种程度上是我们试图在纸面上与彼此进行这些艰难的对话，你知道，因为你不喜欢它，或者因为它不是出自你之手，就像，我想
that's us in some way trying to have these difficult conversations with each other on the page when it's hard to have them in person and and um i don't know i mean that's why you do it is to learn a little more about yourself and this show did teach me a little about myself in terms of i didn't really know kind of i believed in this cycle of all this until we got to the end of the show. And I was like, well, I guess that's the, I guess we wrote these people the way we believe people are.
那在某种程度上是我们试图在纸面上进行这些艰难的对话，当面对面交流很困难时。而且，嗯，我不知道，我的意思是，这就是你做这件事的原因，是为了多了解一点自己。这部剧确实让我对自己有了一些了解，因为在剧集结束之前，我并没有真正意识到我信仰这种循环。当时我想，好吧，我想这就是……我想我们是以我们相信人们本来的样子来塑造这些角色的。
You know, you have to, that seems to be a motif. When in technology being almost like a character on the show, how do you, how do you handle that? I mean, the line that people repeat over and over is it's not,
你知道，你必须……这似乎是一个主题。当技术几乎成为剧中的一个角色时，你是如何处理的？我的意思是，人们反复重复的那句台词是：它不是，
it's not the thing, meaning technology. It's the thing that gets you to the thing. And they're all people who don't have a community, don't have a family, have some sort of obsessive, ambivalent relational style where they really like and also dislike people and really want to be alone and also really don't want to be alone. And that's kind of the driving engine under them, even though everything else is different. And so technology became this thing that they could work on together to connect people. And that's kind of the enemies in the internet. But I mean, how do you handle technology as it changes being almost like the,
它不是那个东西，指的是技术。它是带你通往那个东西的东西。他们都是没有社区、没有家庭的人，有着某种强迫性的、矛盾的关系模式，他们既非常喜欢也讨厌别人，既非常想独处，又非常不想独处。这就是驱动他们的引擎，尽管其他一切都不同。所以技术成了他们可以一起研究来连接人们的东西。这有点像是互联网的敌人。但我的意思是，你是如何处理技术作为……几乎像是，
you know, the silent character? Well, I mean, yeah, I think it becomes this excuse for them to have this family of choice, right? All these people that kind of feel unfulfilled in other ways that they're able to kind of like agree and come together and appreciate the beauty and the project they're working on each year.
你知道，那个沉默的角色？嗯，我的意思是，是的，我认为它成了他们拥有这个“选择的家庭”的借口，对吧？所有这些在其他方面感到不满足的人，他们能够达成一致，聚在一起，欣赏他们每年所从事项目的魅力。
And sometimes more overtly, you know, if it's a game like Cameron's designing, you know, put some charge of themselves out there express themselves but i also think that line thing that gets us to the thing um and i'm sure this was not said at the time ends up being so much about that that thing of how we always kind of place our better life or our happiness in the future you know what i mean like that this is always a bridge to that perfect time where we'll make it or we'll be right or we'll be first or we'll be we'll have the idea and then and then we'll be done uh and the show is that over and over again you know and i and i think that's the human condition at least as i experience it um so i think i think the technology ends up being a little bit of a vessel to talk about that but also we really
有时更明显，你知道，如果这是一个像卡梅伦设计的游戏，你知道，把他们自己的一部分投入其中，表达自己。但我认为那句“带我们通往那个东西”的台词，嗯，我敢肯定当时并没有这么说，但最终却成了关于那种我们总是把更好的生活或幸福寄托在未来的事情。你知道我的意思吗？就像这总是一座通往那个完美时刻的桥梁，在那里我们会成功，或者我们会是对的，或者我们会是第一，或者我们会……我们会拥有那个想法，然后……然后我们就完成了。呃，这部剧一遍又一遍地展示了这一点，你知道，而且我认为这就是人类的处境，至少在我看来是这样。嗯，所以我认为……我认为技术最终成了一个谈论这个话题的容器，但我们也确实
wanted to do right by the people whose story we kind of were telling so um which we felt had been kind of untold so we we really kind of interviewed a lot of people and tried to understand what the i don't know what love for those things was like what what the magic of kind of coding and taking things apart and um knowing something before everyone else knew something felt like and so you know it's some synthesis of our shit and their shit i guess that's what i'm saying yeah well and kind of like i mean though in the hustler you see pool tables and there's people doing pool but you don't have to know anything about the rules of pool you just know it's a show about a character and like what makes a man brave and you know does you know you know when he's doing good you know he's doing bad at pool based on context but you don't have to know anything about it there's no
想善待那些我们讲述其故事的人，所以，嗯，我们觉得他们的故事在某种程度上还没被讲述过。所以我们真的采访了很多人，试图理解对那些东西的热爱是什么样的，那种编码、拆解东西的魔力，以及在别人知道之前就先知道某事的感觉是什么样的。所以，你知道，这是我们和他们的烂事的一种综合，我想这就是我想说的。是的，好吧，就像……我的意思是，虽然在《江湖浪子》里你看到台球桌，人们在打台球，但你不需要了解台球的规则，你只需要知道这是一个关于角色的剧，关于什么让一个人变得勇敢，你知道，你知道他什么时候打得好，什么时候打得不好，这是基于语境的，但你不需要了解任何关于它的知识，没有
like wide shots explaining the game i mean there's also there's no scene where they're like talking about configuring scuzzies for 30 minutes or you know there might be what a bypass driver is and i mean maybe the engineers are doing that in the background but because technology exists as a metaphor you sort of always understand what they're doing, even if you don't have any context for the time. But we did, I will say we tried to thread that needle, which is, I'm not going to claim to be an incredible engineer, but we lived in some ways in fear of the freeze frame where it was like,
那种解释游戏的广角镜头。我的意思是，也没有任何场景是他们谈论配置SCSI接口谈了30分钟，或者你知道，可能什么是旁路驱动程序，我的意思是，也许工程师们在后台做这些，但因为技术是作为隐喻存在的，你通常总是能理解他们在做什么，即使你对那个时代没有任何背景知识。但我会说，我们确实试图穿过那根针，也就是说，我不会自称是一个了不起的工程师，但我们在某种程度上生活在对“定格画面”的恐惧中，就像，
if someone stops this and says, what are their hands on? What are they doing? Or like, what did she write on the board? Or what does it say on the screen? Like it has to be real, right? Because the worst thing that could happen to someone whose story we're telling. And in some ways it's the story of like Compaq and all these other little companies we stole things from for them to watch this and be like, this is bullshit.
如果有人暂停画面说：“他们的手在干什么？他们在做什么？”或者“她在黑板上写了什么？”或者“屏幕上写了什么？”它必须是真实的，对吧？因为对于那些我们讲述其故事的人来说，最糟糕的事情就是……在某种程度上，这是康柏和所有其他我们从中窃取素材的小公司的故事，让他们看到这个并说：“这简直是胡扯。”
You know, like we can't do that because we're probably the one show that's going to try to tell these stories. So we really tried to have that be true but at the same time we have this uh this mantra about like if it seems like they know what they're talking about the audience will go with it it should be true but we don't need to stop and go we don't need a scene where someone like takes a salt shaker and explains that it's the modem and i don't know we don't need to like over explain it but it also needs to not be complete nonsense yeah for sure we're in the middle we lived well yeah then the technology is right like i'm not saying that there's any place where it's where it's wrong it's just that because they're talking about it contextually you know it's accurate um it just isn't that isn't the point that accuracy i hope so yeah yeah i mean did you look to did you
你知道，我们不能那样做，因为我们可能是唯一试图讲述这些故事的剧集。所以我们真的努力让它变得真实，但与此同时，我们有一个关于……如果看起来他们知道自己在谈论什么，观众就会买账的口号。它应该是真实的，但我们不需要停下来去……我们不需要一个场景，有人拿着盐瓶解释那是调制解调器，我不知道，我们不需要过度解释它，但它也不能完全是胡说八道。是的，当然，我们处于中间地带，我们生活得……好吧，是的，那么技术就是正确的，就像我不是说在任何地方它是错误的，只是因为他们是在语境中谈论它，你知道，它是准确的，嗯，它只是……准确性并不是重点，我希望如此。是的，是的，我的意思是，你有没有观察到
look really closely at you know where these people came in and out of history i mean there's a point where joe mcmillan looks a little bit like joe mcafee for a second i mean do you read biographies of those guys or do you just kind of know enough to do what you want to do with the character uh the former that's that's astute we definitely looked at uh mcafee uh for mcmillan especially going into that third season uh yeah we just we read a ton and that's i think that if there's any consistency to my three line um a history major in college i was a researcher in magazines this show really kind of comes out of us wanting to do something like with a glenn gary glenn ross
你有没有仔细观察过这些人是如何进入和离开历史的？我的意思是，有一点乔·麦克米伦看起来有点像乔·麦卡菲。我的意思是，你是读那些人的传记，还是你只是知道得足够多，可以对角色做你想做的事？呃，前者。那很敏锐。我们确实研究了麦卡菲，特别是为了麦克米伦，尤其是在进入第三季的时候。是的，我们读了很多，我认为如果我的三线叙事有什么一致性的话……我在大学是历史专业的，我在杂志社做过研究员，这部剧确实源于我们想做一些类似《拜金一族》的事情，
feel chris's dad having worked a little in computers and so i went to the la public library and got all these books and we found one called breaking big blue that was kind of the story of reverse engineering the ibm pc and just reading like these kind of like nobody read them library books uh and going you know there's there are stories in here and the fact that they're not on the wikipedia yet means you know we can do something people don't necessarily know the punchline to and so i always think that's what you got to do is go way too deep and just see what stays with you and um so hopefully most of the characters feel like not one-to-one but you know that they draw from a variety of real people. And as far as doing a writer's room and two showrunners,
那种感觉。克里斯的父亲在计算机领域工作过，所以我去了洛杉矶公共图书馆，找了所有这些书，我们发现了一本叫《打破蓝色巨人》的书，那是关于逆向工程IBM PC的故事，只是读这些没人读过的图书馆书籍，然后想：“你知道，这里面有故事。”而且它们还没有出现在维基百科上，这意味着我们可以做一些人们不一定知道结局的事情。所以我总是认为这就是你必须做的，深入挖掘，看看什么能留在你心里。所以希望大多数角色感觉不是一对一的，而是你知道，他们取材于各种真实的人。至于建立编剧室和两个剧集主管，
I mean, do y'all have a process? How do you, like, get everybody working at what they're best at? Or was there figuring that out? I don't know. Yeah, we were mentored in our first season by this guy, John Lisko, who came out of, you know, NYPD Blue and Southland and some other things and he was this incredibly benign kind of coach who kind of taught us his offense and then he stepped away to create that show Animal Kingdom and without him I think we would probably have just like sped right into the wall but by the time he left we got the second season we kind of we were ready to just kind of do our thing um and so i think you see a big change into that mutiny world we also like had not done
我的意思是，你们有流程吗？你们是如何让每个人都发挥所长的？还是说那是摸索出来的？我不知道。是的，我们在第一季时由约翰·里斯科指导，他来自《纽约重案组》、《南国警察》和其他一些剧集，他是一个非常温和的教练，他教了我们他的进攻战术，然后他离开去创作《野兽家族》那部剧了。没有他，我想我们可能直接就撞墙上了。但当他离开时，我们到了第二季，我们已经准备好做我们自己的事情了。所以我想你看到了进入那个“叛乱”世界的大转变。我们当时在第一季的收视率也不太好，当时的情况是，好吧，第二季可能是最后一季了，所以让我们……让我们做所有我们一直想在电视上做的事情吧，然后对结果感到满意。结果我们被续订了，那是一个美丽的惊喜。但我认为编剧室的秘诀是，这听起来像是客套话，但就是要创造一个安全的空间，让人们觉得他们可以搞砸，可以非常个人化，可以畅所欲言，
so well in the ratings in the first season where it was like well like the second season is probably the last season so let's just like let's just do all we've ever wanted to do in tv this season and and just just be happy with that and then we got renewed and that was a beautiful surprise. But I think the trick to the writer's room is, this will sound like lip service, but it is just to kind of create a safe space for people to feel like they can bomb and be incredibly personal and kind of say anything
并给人们很大的自主权和投入感，这样你就不会重写别人的东西。我们的房间里有那么多高手和杀手，当好的草稿进来时，我们真的尽量少做改动。然后就是度过一段温暖有趣的时光，我们确实做到了。我回首往事，感到非常亲切。这就像一群人的星座，就像演员一样，你永远无法再把他们全部放在同一部剧里，因为他们都取得了巨大的成功。但是的，我的意思是，对我来说，那是一半的乐趣，坐在那些房间里，开那些玩笑，做出那些发现，并让它走向你从未梦想过的地方。
and to give people a lot of autonomy and investment in it too so you're not like rewriting people we had such like studs and killers in our room that we really tried to change as little as possible when a good draft would come in um and then just to have like a warm fun time and we we really did i i look back on it very fondly it's like a constellation of people much like the actors you could never kind of put it all in the same show again just because they've all gone on to kind of these wild successes but yeah I mean that that's half the fun of it for me is sitting in those rooms and making those jokes and making those discoveries and having it go someplace you never dreamed it would go
是的，那……那项工作对我来说仍然是写作的魔力。你不会认为有一个正确的答案，但当你听到那个东西时，每个人都会“哦，你……哦，你知道……”就像，它有一种能量。所以那是……那是过程中“玄学”的部分，我仍然只是……一种直觉上的合作，几乎就像是在倾听彼此的能量。是的，结果总会有一个最好的版本，你知道。但只有当你开放、安全，而不是……否定想法，或者说它必须是这样，或者试图按食谱烹饪时，你才能达到那个境界。所以这部剧确实被允许拥有那种范围。那么接下来是什么？我的意思是，你说霍尔顿你
yeah it's that that works is still like the magic of writing to me you wouldn't think that there's like a right answer but when you hear the thing everybody just oh you're oh that you know like it uh there is there's an energy to it so that's that's yeah that's the woo part of the process that i still just like an intuitive collaboration of like really listening to each other's energy almost yeah and there just turns out to be like a best version of it in some way you know and but you only get there if you're kind of open and safe and not you know putting ideas down or saying it has to be this or uh kind of trying to cook to a recipe and so that that this show is really allowed to kind of have that range so what what's next i mean you said the halton you
想做《猫的摇篮》剧本，但希望那是为电视写的还是电影？是的，我想那会是一个限定剧集，但你知道，有趣的是，它是……《奔腾年代》结束了，我们接下来要做什么有无数种可能性。我想你意识到事情面临的波折是多么大，而整个经历最终是如此迷人，我们当时就像：“哦，这就是它的运作方式，他们喜欢你的试播集，他们让你拍摄它，他们让你和所有这些很棒的人在一起，每个人都拥抱它，并永远朝着积极的方向发展，阿门。”
wanted to do the cat's cradle uh script but hopefully is that like written more for tv or like a movie yeah i think that's going to be a limited series but you know it's interesting that it was um halt ended and there was like kind of a million possibilities for what we might do next um i guess you realize just like what choppy waters things face and and the whole experience ended up being so charmed and that we were kind of like oh this is how it works is they like they like your pilot and they let you film it and they hear you with all these wonderful people and everyone just kind of uh embraces it and develops it in a positive direction forever and ever amen
嗯，但是的，我的意思是，我认为克里斯和我，无论是一起还是分开，自那以后都经历了几次心碎。那些从未播出的剧集，那些播出了但没有完全按照我们想要的方式实现的剧集，比如《纸女孩》。我没有任何恶意地说。过去10年，尤其是过去5年，这个行业变化太快了。
um but yeah i mean i think both chris and i together and separately have in a positive direction forever and ever. Amen. I think both Chris and I, together and separately, have had a couple heartbreaks since then. Shows that never made it to air, shows that did and kind of didn't quite get realized the way we wanted them to, like Paper Girls. I say without any ill intention. The industry has changed so fast over the past 10 years, especially the last five.
感觉几乎是……我的意思是，当墨迹未干时，你是在向一个不同的行业展示它，你知道吗？我想是这样。罢工和人工智能的辩论也是。我的意思是，我想知道那改变了什么，你知道吗？而且从《奔腾年代》这样的剧集走出来很有趣，因为当你完成那个系列时，你必须在编剧室里意识到，技术比开始时更像是一个反派。你知道，
It almost feels like, I mean, by the time the past 10 years, especially the last five. It almost feels like, I mean, by the time the ink is dry, it's, you're presenting it to a different industry, you know? I think so. The strike and AI debate too. I mean, I wonder what that changes, you know? And it's interesting coming off a show like Halt and Catch Fire, because like, by the time you're finishing that series, you're, you have to be aware in the writer's room, the technology is like a little bit more of a villain than it was at the beginning. You know,
到最后那变得很大，有Facebook数据泄露和各种政治后果。而且，你知道，那是你……？是的，
that was big by the end of there's you having some Facebook data leaks and political, you know, fallout from different things. And, you know, was that something that you were? Yeah,
不，这很有趣。我的意思是，我想，我还没真正谈过这个，但这是真的。就像，
no, it's, it's interesting. I mean, I guess, and I haven't really talked about it, but it is true. It's like,
那是一个更纯真的时代，我们有点像是先驱和特立独行者，他们行动迅速，打破常规。而且，你知道，有《社交网络》，但它还没有变成这种“科技兄弟”的东西。所以我不知道。是的。我不会妄加评判整个行业，但他们看起来确实更像英雄。我们当时在讲述那个故事，
it was a more innocent time where we were kind of like these pioneers and these Mavericks and they're moving fast and breaking things. And that's, you know, there was the social network, but it hadn't yet kind of curdled into this kind of techno bro thing. And it's so, I don't know. Yeah. I wouldn't presume to pass judgment on a whole industry, but they did seem more like heroes. We were kind of telling that story and,
而现在它肯定变得更复杂了。好吧，现在，你知道，就像其中一个……你知道，很多条件只是“我们想要更多的钱”。
and now it's certainly got a little more complex. Well, and now, you know, it's like one of the, you know, a lot of the conditions that were just like, we want more money.
在编剧和演员罢工期间，制片厂很快就屈服了。但特别是对于编剧，巨大的阻碍是他们说：“我们想要有能力永远使用你们的风格，用人工智能，我们想要能够拥有这些东西。”而且，我的意思是，人工智能编写电视节目的想法对我来说是可怕的。我的意思是，第一，因为它无论如何都会比现在市面上很多东西还要糟糕，但第二，你将有能力真正……我不知道，我以一种我认为并不好的方式控制和策划某事，你知道。
The studios cave to pretty quickly during the writer and actor strike stuff. But especially with the writers, the huge holdout was they were like we want to have the ability to use your style forever with ai we want to be able to have this stuff um and i mean the idea of ai writing television is terrible terrifying to me um i mean one just because it wouldn't it would somehow be worse than most of a lot of what is out there but like two you would have the ability to really um i don't know i kind of control and uh curate something in a way that i just i don't think is good you know
是的，我的意思是，我想我来看电视节目是希望看到自己被反映出来，或者感到惊讶，或者我不知道，你知道，能够产生共鸣。对我来说，这成为另一个人来推动那个轮子似乎非常重要。但是，是的，我的意思是，对我来说，人工智能非常明显的恐怖可能性一直是，有时你会得到善意的建议。比如，“就这样做。”你会说，你知道，你保留说“不”的权利。或者，你知道，你不能……你不能拿起我的手强迫我那样做。但人工智能将允许他们拿起你的手说：“但它看起来会是这样。”
yeah i mean i think i come to tv shows kind of hoping to see myself kind of reflected or surprised or i don't know you know be able to kind of identify and it seems to me very essential that that become another human being that kind of beat the wheel of that. But yeah, I mean, to me, the very obvious terrifying possibility of AI has always been that sometimes you get notes that are well-intentioned. Like, do it this way. And you'll go, you know, and you get you reserve the right to say no. Or, you know, you can't you can't pick up my hand and make me do it that way. But AI will allow them to pick up your hand and be like, but it would look like this.
演员也是一样，对吧？他们可以说：“我不说那句台词。”是的，《星球大战》电影。我的意思是，有些人可能在活着的时候签了合同。但是，你知道，彼得·库欣，我的意思是，他知道他还会出现在电影里吗？我的意思是，那……我不想离题太远，但，就像，数字演员的事情让我感到恐惧。你能想象吗？就像把你的肖像权永久地签给某个制片厂，他们可以在你死后把你放进任何电影里，这样你就可以一直出现在背景里？
Ditto with actors, right? They can say, I'm not saying that line. Yeah, the Star Wars movies. I mean, some of the people maybe signed contracts while they were alive. But, you know, Peter Cushing, I mean, was he aware that he was going to still be in movies? I mean, that's... I don't want to digress too much, but, like, the digital actor thing terrifies me. Can you imagine, like, signing of your likeness in perpetuity to some studio that could put you in any movie forever, like, after you're dead, so you could just be in the back?
我不知道。那太疯狂了。就像在你死后，这样你就可以一直出现在背景里。我不知道，那是……是的，我的意思是，你可以看到卡梅伦在听一首朋克歌曲，歌词里谈论着一个公司永远拥有你的灵魂，或者你知道，然后你知道，镜头拉远……是的，而且我……你知道，这很有趣，我现在40岁了。《奔腾年代》是在我30岁时被选中的，我意识到当我进入40岁时，我不想成为那种愤世嫉俗、觉得一切都在走下坡路的人。我非常钦佩的年长者仍然对世界充满好奇和兴趣，并且对那些事物持开放态度。
I don't know. That's wild. like after you're dead so you can just be in the back i don't know that's yeah i mean you could see like cameron listening to a punk song where they're talking about a corporation owning your soul forever or you know and then you know zoom out uh yeah and i you know it's interesting i'm 40 now the hunk gets fired i got picked up when i was 30 and i'm cognizant as i like go into my 40s i of not wanting to be the crusty, it's all going the wrong way kind of guy. The older people I admire so much are just still so curious and interested in the world and kind of open to those things.
我不会撒谎。人工智能是一个很难不让人觉得“呃”的领域。好吧，我只是好奇这如何改变了你作为编剧的过程。我的意思是，你为之写作的世界有点不同，但还有行业挑选事物的方式，以及他们想要它们的方式。我的意思是，激励结构是某种东西，比如流媒体已经比有线电视更奇怪、更不同了，但现在它是这样一种东西，他们说：“哦，是的，不，我们有这个价值十亿美元的流媒体服务，但它注定要亏钱，我们不在乎是否
I'm not going to lie. AI is an area where it's hard not to go like, ugh. Well, I was just curious how that changes your process as a writer. I mean, the world you're writing for is kind of different, but then also just the way that industries pick process as a writer i mean the world you're writing for is kind of different but then also just the way that industries pick things up and how they want them to i mean the incentive structure was something like streaming was already weirder and different than cable but then now it's this thing where they're like oh yeah no we have this billion dollar streaming service but it's supposed to lose money and we don't care if
有人看它，这就是我们现在想要在接下来的两个季度里写的东西。”或者类似的事情。我的意思是，那些是……我不知道，以前有过这种做法吗？这是否改变了你构思项目的方式，还是你只是写你写的，把它扔出去，然后看看它是否……我可能固执地坚持认为，当我们体验到好的东西时，我们仍然知道什么是好的。就像没有人吵着要“给我一部关于芝加哥餐馆的剧”，你知道我的意思吗？两年前，有些东西就是……就像没有人吵着要一部关于德克萨斯州工程师的剧，你知道。我只是认为，如果你试图追逐某种东西，或者试图改变变量以获得成功，或者达到某些目标，那么它就失去了那种个人色彩。
anyone watches it this is what we want written right now for the next two quarters or something i mean the those are i don't know it has has it been done that way before what is does that change the way that you conceive of projects or you just kind of write what you write throw it out there and then see if it i'm clinging to maybe wrong-headedly the idea that we still we still know good when we experience good like like nobody was clamoring for give me a show about a restaurant in chicago you know what i mean like two years ago and there was something about it that just kind of just like no one was clamoring for a show about um engineers in texas you know and i just think if you try to chase a thing or kind of move the variables to be successful or hit certain targets then you're not it loses that personal charge that kind of move the variables to be successful or hit certain targets, then you're not, it loses that personal charge.
它对我来说变得至关重要。所以，也许有更好的编剧能以那种方式烹饪订单。但对我来说，如果我不能在内心感受到它，那么我就……我只是觉得我做不好。所以我不能那样工作。所以你可以感受到它。它是否改变了诸如美学、出现的话题，或者是否有某种基调，或者
It kind of makes it vital to me. And so, so maybe there are better writers who can cook the order in that way. But for me, if I don't, if I can't feel my way inside of it, then I don't, I just don't think I'll do a good job. So I can't work that way. And so you can feel your way inside of it. Does it change just things like the aesthetics of it you know the topics that come up or is there you know a a certain tone to it or
只是节奏，它将如何播出，所有这些你甚至会考虑的事情，或者在后期的重写中？好吧，我的意思是，是的，作为剧集主管的巨大特权是你能够组建你的编剧室，你挑选所有的导演，你挑选所有的演员。所以有太多的机会不去重复自己，并确保你的影响是新鲜有趣的。我总是试着读一些奇怪的东西，我认为它们生活在我接下来要处理的事情的世界里。而且，你知道，我的意思是，所以我感觉我有新的东西，但归根结底，我仍然是，
just the pacing basing how it's on it's going to be aired there's all that stuff that you would even think about at all or that be in rewrites a lot later on well i mean yeah the great privilege of being a showrunner too is you get to get to assemble your writer's room and you pick all the directors and you pick all the actors. And so there's so many chances to kind of not repeat yourself and to kind of make sure your influences are new and interesting. And I always try to read a bunch of weird stuff that I think kind of lives in the world of the thing I'm about to take on next. And, you know, I mean, so so I feel like I have kind of new things, but at the end of the day, I'm still,
我仍然是过滤器。我必须把我所有的工作都通过它。所以可能会有一些相似之处。最近有人向我指出，比如《纸女孩》中的麦克这个角色，可能感觉有点像《奔腾年代》里的卡梅伦。我说，好吧，
I'm still the filter. I have to kind of pass all my work through. So there might be some similarities. And someone pointed out to me recently that like the character of Mac and paper girls, maybe felt a little like Cameron and Hawkish fire. And I was like, well,
你知道，可能是因为我在某个年龄段只听了那么多朋克CD。这就是我在某个点上能汲取的。所以我不知道。但我不知道。你知道，我认为我们来到我们的工作中是为了感到惊讶，我说：“哦，这就是我两年前做那个时在琢磨的东西？”我脱离了那个开发周期，或者进入了一个新的弧线。所以我当时不知道，但这正是它有效的原因，仅仅是因为……好吧，我告诉你，克里斯·坎特韦尔和我写了这个项目，我不认为它会见天日，就像一个位于美丽地方的住宅康复中心，由一个像艾伦·沃茨那样的圣人主持，一个家庭在某种程度上……你知道，处理了现代性的问题，当它涉及到你的手机，以及所有我们正在挣扎的事情时。我想当我们意识到它没成时，我们意识到那是一个我们想成为病人的地方，但也许不是一个我们知道自己在谈论什么的地方。所以是的，我想那是关于非常疲惫和成为新父母，你知道，我的第一个孩子在《奔腾年代》拍摄结束的那周出生，我在拍摄过程中结婚，你知道，克里斯在拍摄期间有了他的第一个孩子，你知道，当你创作一件艺术品时，你的生活会发生转变，希望它们能相互对话。是的，所以我现在感兴趣的东西，我的意思是，我想我们总是会处理那些关于幸福寄托在未来等等的想法，但潜意识里，我想
you know, probably cause I only listened to so many punk CDs when I was a certain age. And that's kind of what I can draw from at a certain point. So I don't know. But I don't know. You know, I think we come to our work to be surprised, and I and said, oh, that's what I was chewing on when I did that two years ago? I'm out of that, you know, cycle of development or onto a new arc. So I didn't know at the time, but that's why this worked just because. Well, I'll tell you, Chris Campbell and I wrote this project that I don't think is ever going to see the light like a residential rehab facility someplace beautiful presided over by like an alan watts like sage and a family that kind of um you know kind of dealt with the problems of modernity uh when it had to do with like your phone and just you know all the things we're struggling with and i think we realized when it didn't go that it was like a place we kind of
你可能确实选择了某些东西，因为有些东西你想在自己身上发泄出来。而且，我只有在回读它时才会发现，这可能是它的走向。好吧，这是一次迷人的谈话。有什么我们没触及的吗？
wanted to be patients but maybe not a place that we kind of knew what we were talking about so yeah uh i think that was about being pretty exhausted and new parent you know um my first child was born the week halt and catch fire wrapped filming um i got married in the middle of it uh you know chris had his first kid during it you know it was your life transforms while you're making a piece of art and hopefully they kind of can speak to each other yeah and so the stuff i'm interested in now i mean i think we'll always be contending with those ideas of happiness being placed in the future and whatnot but subconsciously i think
你觉得这很重要，或者你想说，我不想……我不想占用你的时间。呃，
you probably do choose things because there's there's something you want to get out in yourself. And, uh, I'm only going to find out when I read it back, it's probably the way it'll go. Well, this is a fascinating talk. Is there anything that we don't touch on?
不，只是，你知道，我想我在我们开始之前说过，我非常感谢收到你这封非常好的邮件。对我来说，这部剧持续存在的东西就是人们在多年后似乎还能发现它，并与它有个人体验。那真是太令人欣慰了，你知道，因为我认为每个创作东西的人在某种程度上
You feel like it's relevant or that you want to say, I don't, I don't want to, uh, take, I don't want to go over your, your time. Uh,
都想被看见和理解。所以我认为我们添加了我们自己。我认为“欣赏”这个词意味着增加价值。我们把自己添加到了我们欣赏的事物中。我非常感谢你欣赏这部剧，并把自己添加进去，给了我谈论它的机会。好吧，非常感谢你。你真是太好了。
no, only that, you know, uh, I think I said this before we began uh i was i was so grateful to receive this this really nice kind of email from you and the thing that continues to endure about this show for me is just that people seem to find it many years later and and have a personal experience with it um and that just is so gratifying, you know, because I think everybody who makes something on some level
祝你接下来的一切顺利。我很期待。你也是。《糖》第二季。你知道他们是否用了同样的？我想最近有一部丹泽尔·华盛顿的恐怖电影，叫什么来着？《细微差别》。电影，就像……叫什么来着……《细微差别》。我想房子和他在《糖》第一季里的处理者是一样的，但我不太确定，我只是
wants to kind of be seen and understood. And so I think we add ourselves. I think the word appreciate means to add value to. We add ourselves to the things we appreciate. And I'm just so grateful you appreciated this and added yourself to it and gave me a chance to talk about it. Well, thank you so much. That's really kind of you.
天哪，我不会感到惊讶。有很多东西，因为这需要从亚特兰大拍摄热潮开始，所以我的意思是，像《耐撕侦探》，有无数这样的东西。我心想，那是……你知道，那是汤姆·德克斯。你知道，你看到……你有了某种眼光，你开始到处看到这些东西。所以是的，如果《糖》里的酒店被用在……是那个吗？不，是那个他的处理者住的房子。它只是有……数字在路边，
And good luck with everything you've got coming up. I'll look forward to it. You too. Season two of Sugar. Do you know if they use the same? I think there's a recent Denzel Washington horror movie that was like, what was it called? The Little Things. movie that was like uh what was it called uh little the little things i think the i think the house is the same as like his handler and in the first season of sugar but i wasn't sure i just
而且几乎有同样的镜头，看起来完全一样。我会检查并回复你。但是的，我想一旦你知道了，每个汽车广告都是在洛杉矶市中心的同一条街上拍摄的。所以就是这样。是的，洛杉矶有很多地方被拍摄过很多次。是什么？
oh man i wouldn't be surprised there's a ton of stuff because it requires from like the beginning of the boon in atlanta filming so i mean like the nice guys there's a million of those. And I'm like, that's, you know, that's Tom Dex. That's, you know, you see, you get certain eyes, you start to see this stuff everywhere. So yeah, I wouldn't be surprised if, is it the hotel and sugar is used in, is it that? No, it's the, the house that his like handler or something lives at. It just has like the numbers are on this curb,
哦，我知道。有一件事我忘了问你，我一直很好奇那个在综合大楼里卖打印机的兄弟，他们是基于蒂姆和埃里克吗？他们是蒂姆和埃里克吗？他们有蒂姆和埃里克的风格。我不知道他们是否明显是。我知道其中一个演员，巴拉克，有点私交，他是朋友的朋友，他确实有一种韦尔海姆的氛围。是的。写那个场景的编剧，马克·拉弗蒂，
and there was almost the same kind of shot, and it looked exactly like the same. I will check and get back to you. But yeah, I think once you know, every car commercial is filmed on the same street in downtown LA. So there it is. Yeah, there's a lot of places in LA that have been shot quite a few times. What is it?
后来去管理其他项目了。我以为只是直接倾向于那种风格。所以是的，那是一个令人愉快的、持久的。是的，第一季，到最后变得非常有趣。它确实非常聪明。我只是认为它必须是这样，
Oh, I know. One thing I forgot to ask you i've always wondered about that the the brothers that sell the printer uh at the complex thing was that were they based on tim and eric were they like tim and eric was that they're tim and eric-esque um i don't know if overtly they were i know one of the actors uh barack a little bit personally he was like a friend of a friend and He definitely gives a little Wareheim vibe. Yeah. The writer who wrote that, Mark Lafferty,
因为就像你说的，如果你谈论计算机，它可能会有点枯燥，我可能会写一部人们99%的时间都在表达情感的剧，但我真的很高兴那是剧集的一部分，让你笑得和哭得一样多，因为我认为前者让你为后者做好准备，这就是生活。好吧，嗯，那太完美了，非常感谢你。有什么地方我可以指引人们去吗？除了链接到《纸女孩》仅在亚马逊上可用的地方，其他东西我相信可以在几个地方流媒体播放。还有什么我可以指引人们去的吗？你有网站或IMDb页面，任何你想要在节目说明里的东西？不，只是……你知道，看这些东西。爱你所爱的。
has gone on to run stuff. I thought just leaned right into that. So yeah, that's a delightful and enduring. Yeah. The first season, it gets so funny at the end. It really is just very clever. I just think it has to be too
提防彼此。因为一切都即将改变。世界即将裂开。地平线上有东西。一种巨大的连接。我们之间的障碍将消失。而我们还没有准备好。我们将以新的方式伤害彼此。我们将出卖，也将被出卖。
because like you said it can be a little dry if you talk about computers and i would probably write a show where people just emoted 99 of the time but i'm really glad that's on the fire of the show where you laugh as much as you cry because i think i think the one kind of softens you up for the other and that's life well um that's that's perfect thank you so much and is there anywhere that i can point people to um other than linking to the places where uh paper girls is only available at amazon the other stuff i believe um is available to stream a couple places is there anything else i can point people to you got a website or an imdb page anything you want the show notes no just see you know watch the stuff. Love what you love.
因为就像你说的，如果只谈论电脑，可能会有点枯燥。我可能会写一部人们 99% 的时间都在表达情感的剧，但我真的很高兴这部剧能让你又哭又笑，因为我认为前者会让你对后者产生共鸣，这就是生活。嗯，这太完美了，非常感谢。除了链接到《纸女孩》在亚马逊上的播放地址外，还有什么地方我可以推荐给观众吗？其他作品我记得可以在几个地方观看。还有什么我可以推荐的吗？你有网站或 IMDb 页面吗？或者任何你想放进节目笔记的东西？不，只要去看就行了。去爱你们所爱的一切吧。
Beware of each other. Because everything's about to change. The world is going to crack wide open. There's something on the horizon. A massive connectivity. The barriers between us will disappear. And we're not ready. We'll hurt each other in new ways. We'll sell and be sold.
提防彼此。因为一切都将改变。世界即将彻底裂开。地平线上有什么东西。一种巨大的连接。我们之间的隔阂将会消失。而我们还没有准备好。我们将以新的方式伤害彼此。我们将出卖，也将被出卖。
We'll expose our most tender selves only to be mocked and destroyed. We'll be so vulnerable. And we'll pay the price. We won't be able to pretend that we can't protect ourselves anymore. It's a huge danger. A gigantic risk. But it's worth it. If only we can learn to take care of each other. Then this awesome, destructive new connection won't isolate us. It won't leave us in the end, so...
我们将展现出自己最柔软的一面，却只换来嘲笑和毁灭。我们将变得如此脆弱，并为此付出代价。我们将无法再假装自己无法保护自己。这是一种巨大的危险，一个巨大的风险。但这是值得的。只要我们能学会照顾彼此，那么这种令人敬畏且具有破坏性的新联系就不会孤立我们。它最终不会抛弃我们，所以……
Totally alone. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
彻底孤独。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。